hello youtube and welcome to another hd
tutorial and this one first of all i
have to apologize for not being able to
get to you guys uh right away on the
sony vegas 8 intro tutorial i'm having
some trouble keeping it under 10 minutes
long so i'm not a youtube partner as of
today so i will have to um i have to
experiment later probably put it in a
video series instead of one long 12
minute video so anyway today i'm going
to be showing you you can see by the
title how to use a micro sd card
basically the uses that i use in a micro
sd card um i have a four gig micro sd
card here and i have just how i use it
and what i can use with the adapter and
everything so first of all i have an lg
voyager right here which does have a
micro sd card the iphone 3g does not so
i'm using this one for the tutorial
it does have the slot on the side so i
went out and bought myself a four gig
micro sd card by sandisk um this is
relatively fast flash memory but
basically if i wanted to insert into the
phone
it's very very simple um i'll try to
show you guys at an angle here you just
kind of slide it in
and the phone actually does light up
because it realizes you've inserted some
storage so
there you go and i just closed it up
there and the memories in the phone now
i do use this uh micro sd card to uh
with all the memory
of the entire phone basically so if i
were to put a new song on the phone i
would put it on a micro sd card if i
were to take a new couple of pictures a
few high-res pictures as this does have
a great camera then i would use the
micro sd card
but a lot of people don't feel like
transferring files from a micro sd card
to the phone via bluetooth to their
computer so i went out and olympus was
nice enough to include one of these
when i purchased a digital camera this
is a micro sd card
attachment which is basically the size
of an sd card but does have a slot to
slide in a micro sd card in the top so
i'm going to show you guys how this
works and
it's really nice that they included this
because you can um as i i'll try to
slide this in here you can um
you can slide the sd card itself or the
sd adapter the whole thing into your
laptop so i'm just going to slide it in
and that's all it takes so this is
already in and if you plug this as an sd
card into your computer's card reader it
will recognize everything that's on your
micro sd card so you'll be able to pick
up the photos you took on your phone the
photos you may have taken on your micro
sd card device
so um i'm gonna pause this video and
come back
excuse me i'm gonna pause this video and
i'm gonna show you guys um
how i use it on my laptop and a few
other things that i use it for
all right guys here's the laptop and
i've already showed you guys the laptop
is closed right now i'll just open it up
so um first of all this is the micro sd
card attachment and this happens to be
the card reader on my laptop so i'm
actually going to bring the camera down
and show you guys uh that it does fit
this is the card reader it does read sd
mmc
ms ms pro and xd um this camera right
now is recording on an xd card but if i
wanted to take that picture again like i
said i could just go ahead and slide it
right in here and it would be able to be
read by the laptop so that's pretty cool
that i don't have to use bluetooth or
anything like that to waste battery and
to transfer my files to my laptop
another great feature of this combo is
that you can actually take
pictures that you've taken from your
digital camera that you'd like to save
on an xd or mmc card and transfer them
even more easily so here's what it is if
you have if you don't have a memory card
and all you have is a micro sd card for
your cell phone and a an sd attachment
what you can do is take the micro sd
card and put it into the sd attachment
and you can use this and record your
videos and such on your phone um i'm
sorry on your digital camera so you can
put this into your digital camera and
use it to record video and audio i'm
sorry oh video and audio and all of that
video and audio will be instantly um
pretty much very easily transferred to
your laptop again via the sd card reader
on the laptop so it's pretty cool that
you can do that you can use this
actually as a as like a makeshift sort
of a memory card for it for your digital
camera but it really is a memory card so
it's very good that you can uh that you
can do that so thanks for olympus for
including this micro sd attachment in
the uh and the purchase that i made and
that's basically it so uh thanks for
watching this hd tutorial you guys i'm
really like that i can do hardware stuff
and software stuff now i've begun
emailing a few companies asking them if
they would like me to do reviews of
their products for them since i don't
really see a lot of videos of certain
things that i'd like to show show you
guys so again thanks for watching this
tutorial and stay tuned for that sony
vegas
effects video series basically so yeah
thanks for watching this one and i hope
you enjoyed subscribe for more and
that's basically it peace